- Thank you so much, Meredith,
for that introduction.
I was telling her earlier
that, every time she
introduces one of us, we leave
feeling really motivated,
and like, is she
talking about me?
Is this my work?
Am I that amazing?
So I appreciate that.
I also want to say thank you
to everyone at the Radcliffe
Institute.
You all take such
good care of us
and make us feel so
special-- everyone
from Jess, who always
gives me a warm smile when
I walk in the building, to
the folks who have helped me
when I've locked myself
out of the office at night.
So I'm thankful to you all.
And also I want to say thank
you to my fellow Fellows,
many of whom have heard me
speak about my research.
And so it's a pleasure to
present it in more fullness
and richness, I hope, today.
But also to friends
and colleagues
who are on various
fellowships across campus
that I've been able to connect
with since I've been here.
Thank you to you all, especially
my folks from the Hutchins
Center who came over to see me.
I'm glad that you're here.
So let me just say that this
is my first time presenting
any of this research, so
I want to allow myself
to be loose with it and have
some fun, because, as Meredith
said, I'm a serious scholar, but
I also like to bring some humor
and hilarity to my work because
I think it keeps me grounded,
and it keeps me human and
realizing that I'm not just
a thinker.
I'm also a three
dimensional being.
So I want to bring some of
that energy to the podium
tonight as I present on this
work, "The Glamorous Life--
Socialite Activists and
the Black Freedom Struggle
from World War II to
the Age of Obama."
First I'd like to say
I'm sorry to anyone
who wanted to hear me talk
about Barack Obama in depth.
I won't be doing that tonight.
I'm kind of starting from
the front end of the project.
So most of it will be about
this immediate post-World War II
era, but I'm more than happy to
let you know what I'm thinking
about Barack Obama--
in particular, one of his early
members of his administration
who I might speak about
in a little bit of detail
if there's enough time
towards the end of my talk.
But I'm happy to talk about
Barack Obama during the Q&A.
So the first kernels
of this product
actually date back
to graduate school
when I was working on my
first book, Liberated Threads,
and I'll give you a
sense of how I arrived
at this topic a little bit
later on, but my interest in it
never died.
When you're a graduate
researcher and you say,
oh, this is going to be
my second book because you
find a few interesting
documents in the archive,
but does it really
become the second book?
So I guess technically this
will be my second book,
but it is one of my--
the project that I
imagined then-- it still
is very similar to what
I imagined then in terms
of its shape and scope.
And I used the Schomburg
Center Fellowship
to collect much of
the archival material
that I'll present
on today, but it
wasn't until this last
semester at the Radcliffe
that I was able
to actually start
analyzing some of that data.
So what I'm going to
be presenting tonight
are some of my first
impressions about a lot
of the research I
found in the archive
while I was at the
Schomburg Center.
Tea and shade, an introduction.
And for me it's
a way of thinking
about the embodiment of
the women in this era
that they were living through--
tea and shade.
How many people are familiar
with this language, tea
and shade?
I know.
You're probably like,
oh, I knew that.
As soon as I said
it, you're like,
I already know what
tea and shade means.
She don't have to tell me.
But I'm going to tell you
a little bit about how
tea and shade informs
how I'm thinking
about these socialite
activist women.
So in spring 1954, the
New York Amsterdam News
published a series of stories
on black society women.
Betty Granger, the series
author and Amsterdam News
social editor, argued
that society life
had changed quite
drastically since the days
when A'Lelia Walker reigned as
the queen of black social life
in New York City.
The millionaire heiress
to the Madam C.J. Walker
beauty empire hosted
lavish events,
both at her Manhattan
apartment and also
at her Westchester county
estate villa, [INAUDIBLE]..
By the time of Granger's
series, the original black 400
had all but died off, and many
of their customs, rituals,
and standards had
perished with them.
Who was the current grand
dame of black society?
Granger wanted to know.
What were the new requirements
for becoming a social leader?
Granger wrote, "we
want our readers
to decide in true democratic
fashion exactly who rules
supreme as New York's
modern day social queen."
For three weeks,
the Amsterdam News
accepted letters and
postcards from readers
who casted their votes.
And the letters poured
in even from people
who didn't live in New York, but
who wanted to offer commentary
on the so-called black elite.
Commenting on the
old guard rules
for becoming part of
the negro aristocracy,
Granger reminded
readers that it's long
been said that to join the
ranks of black society you must,
quote, "take a woman with some
family background [? add in ?]
a basic education, toss
in some accessible cash,
and mix plentifully with
membership in one or two
nationally established
clubs or sororities.
And there you have the
fundamental requirements
for our social
potpourri," unquote.
Yet she notes that
there were regional,
or even state to
state differences.
She claimed that
in the Midwest--
notably Chicago and Detroit--
it's money and more money
that makes an ambitious gal
eligible for high society.
In Atlanta, she
says it's education.
A PhD is your best bet
for social success.
In Charleston, South Carolina,
your rank in the social order
is gauged by quote, "the
paleness of your skin."
And in Boston, she says it's
family background and nothing
else that lets you in.
So she notes here that,
whereas people had just
accepted these rules
pretty much as gospel,
that in the post World War
II era, that people were
challenging these ideas, and
that there was opportunity
for people who never
would have been considered
part of black society to
now enter that said society.
So people were
critiquing colorism,
possessing distinguished
family name, and requirement
of generational wealth.
Well, essentially the
whole entire system--
everything she said that people
wanted you to have to be a part
of society--
she says now it's
pretty much a no go.
People are trying to
throw out these old rules.
So at the end of the
three week voting period,
Granger noted that they
received hundreds of letters
from readers near and far.
And the Amsterdam
News, of course,
published the most
provocative missives.
And again, let me say people
had many feelings on the topic.
And they was all up
in their feelings.
So for example, Ms. Avis
[? Malcoa, ?] an employee
of the Edison Hotel, goes in,
calling out what she considers
the types of socialites--
the nasty snobs with too much
useless education, the
dumb yellow chicks--
these are her words, not mine--
who use their good looks to make
up for their lack of pedigree,
and the big shot women who
lucked into wealth by hitting
the lottery, but have
none of the social graces.
For example, she says, they buy
Cadillacs with their winnings,
throw wild parties, drink all
the brown liquor, and, quote,
"wind up talking
loud and wrong."
[LAUGHTER]
[? Malcoa ?] pivots to
acknowledge the women
she feels are outstanding
members of our race,
women who have given
unselfishly to uplift the race--
the entire race, not
just a particular class.
She names Mary
McLeod Bethune, who
you're going to hear
about in a little bit,
and Marian Anderson as examples.
Eva Tucker, a member of the
Metropolitan Mothers Club--
so she would have been one
of these society women--
wrote in saying that the
modern social leader must
be an intelligent career woman,
who must have distinguished
themselves in this community
in terms of civic leadership.
She must entertain in good
taste and smart style,
because according
to Tucker, quote,
"Madam Walker's style
of big time entertaining
is no longer fashionable.
People woke up to the
fact a long time ago
that spending hundreds and
maybe even thousands of dollars
on food and drink
for would be friends
wasn't the smartest thing in
the world to do," end quote.
On the top of Eve Tucker's
list, a society leader
who met all of her
requirements was
a woman who most
people in this room
have never heard of before--
Mollie Moon.
My talk will center on Moon,
the undisputed social queen
of Harlem in the
mid 20th century.
In her obituary in
1990, Jet magazine,
one of the black
bibles, wrote that Moon
had raised $3.4 million for
the National Urban League,
and she'd also helped fundraiser
for other smaller Harlem based
organizations and institutions.
Moon is most known for
founding the Urban League Guild
and serving as president
of the Guild for 50 years.
That's a long time.
[LAUGHTER]
That should tell you something
about her personality.
I'm just saying.
The Urban League Guild was the
social wing of the National
Urban League that helped
translate the organization's
mission to everyday people
and wealthy would be donors.
In short, they made the
organization look cool and have
broader appeal.
In hip hop parlance, the Guild
was the hype man to the emcee.
I first learned of Mollie
as a graduate student
trying to learn
all I could about
black nationalist protests
against a white owned wig shop.
And the more I learned about her
and the Beaux-Arts costume ball
and beauty pageant the
Guild hosted each year,
the more I became
intrigued not only
by how she raised
all of that money
and for which specific
causes, but by the culture
of fundraising and the
lifestyle of a fundraiser,
a social and
political powerbroker
and the powerbroker's
role within this larger
constellation of activists
and intellectuals
who feature prominently in
civil rights movement history.
And I've been followed
following the money trail,
and it's led me to some
interesting places--
some scandalous places, even.
I've also discovered the names
of other women like Mollie
who have used their social cache
and extensive networks to host
both public and private events
for a range of organizations
devoted to racial equality.
So the scholarship
has taught us--
and it's a rather
robust scholarship
that says that black women were
the backbone of the movement.
No matter what period
of time we look
at, this is true, whether we are
talking about the civil rights
movement, the feminist
movement, the Black
Lives Matter movement of today.
Women are the backbone.
However, the nature
and international scope
of their fundraising
has gone understudied.
So what I've been
trying to do then
is piece together this history
and understand why these women
are not in the historiography.
So I think part of the problem
is a question about paradigms.
So in my first book,
Liberated Threads,
I tried to introduce
a new way or paradigm
for studying the
civil rights movement,
because what I'd realized was
that black women's activism had
been kind of categorized
into these types--
so the respectable church lady
and the radical freedom fighter
being two of them that have
emerged from this time period
as lenses for seeing
and understanding
black women's cultural
and political activism--
and also because questions
of periodization and subfield
specific questions
have meant that Mollie
Moon and her generation
have not been highly visible
because they haven't fit neatly
within the black women's club
movement literature,
which typically ends
at the start of World War II.
And temporally,
Mollie's generation
considered themselves
patrons of the arts.
That was one of their
major commitments
in terms of their
activism, and they'd
fall into this lacuna between
the scholarship of the Harlem
Renaissance in the '20s
and '30s and the black arts
movement in the '60s and '70s.
So for me, I'm
interested in what
they were doing in
the '40s and '50s
as it relates to black
arts and the protection
and proliferation of black
arts in that time period.
Also, I find that we don't
see them in the old left
to new left conversation,
which typically doesn't focus
on black women much
at all, but they also
haven't been taken up in
this black internationalism
scholarship either.
And they also aren't part of
this black intellectual history
turn, because they sit at
this interesting and quite
challenging to recover
intersection of civil rights
history, business history,
beauty and grooming culture,
fashion, consumer and economics,
and also material culture.
So there's this small yet
burgeoning body of scholarship
that does this type
of recovery work.
So I would say my first two
books, I think, do this work
and try to establish a way for
doing this work through what I
call eclectic archiving, which,
as Meredith mentioned earlier,
requires me to draw from a lot
of different types of source
material and also take an
interdisciplinary approach
to the study of history.
But then there is
also Robert Weems,
Desegregating the Black Dollar.
Susannah Walker,
Style and Status.
My colleague Tiffany
Gill's Beauty Shop Politics
and her new book on
black women and travel.
And as we talk more and
more about our work,
we realize we have so
many women in common
they overlap in our work.
And then also Quincy Mills,
Cutting Along the Color Line,
and his new project,
The Wages of Resistance,
which also looks at how the
civil rights and black power
organizations negotiated their
need for funds and fundraising
with their anti capitalist and
anti imperialist ideologies.
In my own work, I'm toying with
this concept of black glamor
as a guiding
framework to uncover
the modes of embodied activism
that Mollie and her peers
employed.
It began with my fascination
with our collective fascination
with the black glamor set.
Entire Tumblrs and
Instagrams have
been devoted to celebrating
black history of glamor
as a way to celebrate
our humanity, our style,
our pleasure and joy,
the beauty of our people,
to challenge the notion that
high femininity and refinement
was solely for white women--
that black women have
been about that life,
which is really true.
Look at any time period.
Black women have been glamorous.
Thus glamor becomes
an interesting way
to examine insider-outsider
cultures and class
categories that become much
more malleable when we think
of glamor as a
performance, one that
is often more about
aspiration than what
one has in the bank account.
So by winning the battle
on the taste lines, if not
the front lines,
of the movement,
Moon and those who
followed in her footsteps
influenced modern rules of
etiquette, style, and party
planning that continue to be
promulgated by Ladies Home
Journal and W magazine.
So these women, with their
impeccable sense of style,
and good looks, and
cosmopolitan charm,
had the cultural capital
necessary to host
these star studded
fundraising events
and exclusive parties that
brought politicians, activists,
and prominent philanthropists,
such as the Rockefellers,
the Vanderbilts,
and the Fields--
of the Marshall Field's
department store empire--
and so forth into
conversation with one another
and with a wider movement.
So I delve into this opulent
world of the black middle class
or this black elite
to examine how
conspicuous
consumption, pleasure,
and leisure culture
both coalesce with
and undermine the aims of
the Black Freedom Project.
Specifically, I,
like Quincy Mills,
am thinking critically
about how Moon and her ilk
are touting relationships
with families whose names are
synonymous with American
capitalism and heads of state
in the British empire--
of the British empire
in the Caribbean,
while activists
like Claudia Jones
are using every platform
possible to dismantle
imperialism.
But somebody has got
to raise the money.
[LAUGHTER]
So if we look at all
of these organizations,
we see some ties
that raise eyebrows.
Enter the tea and the shade.
So these women were hyper
visible in the archive,
and in my own archive I now
have over 2,000 clippings
from black newspapers
on Moon and Eunice
Johnson, who features
prominently in the work,
and also Desiree Rogers, who
was the first social secretary
of the Obama administration.
And when I'm reading
these newspaper clippings
and putting them in
conversation with all sorts
of other material, including
literature and menus
from the venues they
hosted their events,
from personal correspondence, I
see that the tea was spilling,
and the shade was intense,
especially from the Baltimore
Afro-American.
That was a shady newspaper.
I love them.
I love reading their account
of this black high society
and the fact that they feel
like, from their vantage point
in Baltimore, they
have the ability
to speak on what's happening
in New York, the big town
black society, in ways that the
New York Amsterdam News can't
because they are essentially a
vehicle of the National Urban
League.
So I want to just talk a little
bit about Mollie, a woman
that I have really
come to admire a lot.
I love her.
I love writing about
complicated black women,
and she is complicated,
and complex,
and messy in all the ways that
makes my job as a historian
and a storyteller fun.
So I love her.
So to put it bluntly,
Mollie was a hustler.
Mollie came from a family
of no importance that
wasn't at all wealthy, and that
had migrated from the south
to the Midwest.
And in the Midwest, I'm
talking about Gary, Indiana.
And I can say it like that
because I'm from Indiana.
So by the time I encounter
Mollie in the archive,
she is moving back and forth
between New York and Gary.
She was born allegedly in 1912.
I don't know.
I just like these women--
are you really telling
the truth about your age?
I don't really know.
So many of her
background details
are sketchy because
she, like a lot of women
in this interwar period who
were moving across the US,
were using this
as an opportunity
to remake themselves.
So Mollie attended
Meharry Medical College,
and she earned a
degree in pharmacy.
She takes a few classes at
Columbia's teacher college,
and she eventually becomes a
social worker of all things.
And she meets
Henry Lee Moon, who
will become her husband,
on a trip to Russia
in the early 1930s.
So she did her bit
to study abroad,
and she was learning
German, too.
And Henry is also
from the midwest,
and he's from Cleveland, but
from a more prominent family.
His father actually founded
the chapter of the NAACP
in Cleveland.
Henry has a degree from Howard.
He pledged Omega Psi Phi, so he
has the fraternity credentials
there.
He earned a master's
degree, and he's
a journalist writing for the
Amsterdam News when they meet.
He goes on to become
a public relations
director for the NAACP and
also a writer for the crisis.
While Mollie's moving back and
forth between her mother's home
in Gary and New York City, where
she's meeting all these folks,
she finds that she has
a knack for meeting
wealthy, wealthy people--
prominent writers.
For example, I was digging
around in the Schlesinger
archive, and I found
this letter from Mollie
to writer Dorothy West.
And in it, Dorothy--
for people who
don't know, Dorothy
is the daughter of one of
the wealthiest black families
in Boston.
And Mollie is saying
to her, I'm flat broke.
We should move in together.
[LAUGHTER]
You can help me pay my bills,
and we can split our rent.
I think she says here it
would be $14 for each of us
if we move in together.
So she has this knack
for meeting people,
for making friends.
She's good at corresponding and
keeping in touch with people.
And so by the time she marries
Henry Lee Moon in 1938,
she is known for being
this active woman
on the social scene
in New York City.
And let me just say
this as an aside.
It just made me love
her more, but when
they start corresponding--
I've been all up
in their letters--
they write the way we text.
I mean, there's just
so many letters,
and he was pretty much
engaged to this other woman.
And so Mollie's writing him,
oh, hey, hey, all this stuff.
They're friends.
And then before you know
it, she has him paying
her mother's medical bills.
[LAUGHTER]
I was like, yes, Mollie.
So anyway, she ends up
moving to New York City,
and they get married.
They get a place
together, and they
become known as the socialite
and the intellectual.
They both see themselves
as race people.
She's a race woman.
So she's not just
a party planner.
She is also a woman
who cares very
much about the equality
of black people
and ending racial disparities.
And so she first
tries to mold herself
after some of these women of the
black 400, as they were known,
these women who--
are you familiar with
this language of the 400?
In the late 19th
century it was this idea
that, oh, we're going
to throw this party,
and we're going to invite--
it can fit 400
people, so we're only
going to invite the most
important 400 society people.
So then, of course, black
people had their version
of this, the black 400.
So Mollie is trying
to model herself
after Bessye Bearden, who
is Romare Bearden's mom
and very active on the social
and art scenes in Harlem.
But by the time she
establishes the Guild in 1942,
she realizes that
this is her place,
that this is the way that
she can make her mark.
And so in 1947, the
Los Angeles Sentinel
writes "undisputed
Harlem hostess
beyond comparison this season is
individual dynamic Mollie Moon.
Her parties gather the most
fascinating people in town.
They're like the
Negro Renaissance
era in flavor and texture.
Nobody in town can come near
her for sheer excellence
in unusual party giving.
She reigns supreme
and legendary."
So these are some images
from an Urban League luncheon
that Mollie is hosting.
Mollie is standing with
the white blazer on.
So then a pivotal moment
happens in her career
as this socialite who's trying
to really emerge as a race
woman, as well.
In May, 1951, Mollie
called the Hotel Pierre
to book the rooftop garden and
secure catering for a party
to be held on the
evening of July 20.
Now, the key to being
a successful socialite
and hostess is--
as you can imagine, I'm sure--
location, location, location.
You have to have the dopest
spots to have your events--
period.
People want to go
somewhere that they
can feel like, oh, yes,
this is the place to be.
So she's hosting the Urban
League's wealthiest donors
at this event,
and so she decides
that the Pierre, with its
Upper East Side address--
it sits at 2 East 61st
and Fifth Avenue--
have that air of
refinement and exclusivity
that Mollie needed
for the event.
Plus it was a visually
stunning hotel from its decor
to its unobstructed
views of Central Park.
And so she calls over
the phone to book
the garden on the roof for
her event, and she's told,
sure, yes, you can
book the event there.
We can get the catering
set up, et cetera.
So then Mollie strolls into
the Pierre to pay her deposit.
This is how I imagine
she walked in there.
[LAUGHTER]
I don't know.
And then I imagine her sounding
like Eartha Kitt and saying,
yes, darling, I'm here
to pay my deposit.
So she goes to pay this
deposit, and the assistant
to the catering manager
is like, oh, no.
That room is closed.
It's booked that day.
I think they told her
it was booked that day,
and they told her it was closed.
They told her both.
It's closed for repairs,
and it's already booked.
And so she was saying, well,
hey, I was told over the phone
that I can make this booking.
And he's like, no, you can't.
The man she spoke to on
the phone, a guy named
WM [? Willey, ?] refused
to speak to her in person.
And a couple of days later,
Mollie had one of her friends
go in there then
since they refused
to give her the booking--
the wife of a prominent
Wall Street attorney
named Elizabeth
[? Fillman ?] and she
had her attempt to book the
rooftop for that same day.
So [? Willey, ?]
the banquet manager,
asked [? Fillman ?] if any
colored persons would be
attending the event
she was planning.
He reminded her that the
Pierre was a high class hotel.
Once she assured him that
no Negroes would be present,
he accepted her booking.
Well, that was all the
proof Mollie needed.
She filed a lawsuit against
Getty Realty Corporation,
the company that owned the
hotel, the banquet manager,
and his assistant under the
sections 40 and 41 of the New
York State Civil
Rights Law concerning
public accommodations.
And then [? Fillman ?] and
another person whom Molly
had booked the
rooftop for that day--
for the day before,
actually, since she
was told that it was--
one of the excuses
they gave her that it
was closed for repairs.
She had both of them
testify for her in court.
And the judge
presiding over the case
was a man named Abraham
Goodman, who presided over
one of the first cases
tried in New York following
the enactment of the
civil rights law.
So Mollie won her case and
received a $600 settlement.
So the max she could receive
was $500 per defendant,
and so she wins this $600, and
people see this as a victory.
And the Baltimore Afro-American
writes the Urban League Guild
was, quote, "more militant
than the parent group
which organized it."
Shade, right?
I just love it.
So they're saying basically
that Mollie was bold enough
to do something that
even the Urban League
Guild doesn't use as a tactic.
She was using the court
systems in her favor,
and once she did this, her
popularity really skyrocketed.
Just as a note of aside
here in terms of methods,
once I found this lawsuit,
I started to, A, look
to see if there were
other similar lawsuits.
Are these socialite women who
want to host garden rooftop
parties saying, well, listen,
if you won't give us bookings,
we will sue you.
Some I'm looking for
that, but I'm also
keeping a list of hotels
that are mentioned
in the black press as
places that allowed
them to host these events.
And so here's a
list of the names
that I've come across so far.
Now, I will admit
most of my research
has been going through documents
based on Mollie in New York
City, so I imagine
that, as I dig
into the research
in DC and Chicago,
more hotels will be
added to this list.
So like I said,
after this event--
after the lawsuit,
Mollie's popularity soars.
And she's honored as woman
of the year for her 14
years of [? inspiring ?]
and distinguished leadership
with the Urban League
Guild, the Harlem Hospital
Auxiliary, and the
Spence-Chapin adoption service.
And it's noted in
the publication--
this is not about that--
I just like this because she's
wearing a fur and a big hat,
and I love a big hat.
But this image-- it just kind
of speaks to the identity
that she's trying to
create at the time.
But when she
receives this award,
Ralph J. Bunche presents
her with the award,
and so the black press
is like, Mollie's famous.
Ralph Bunche is presenting
her with an award.
And then the legendary
journalist and society woman
Gerri Major, who was
part of the black 400,
toasted Mollie, as well
as her very good friend,
Jeanne Murray Vanderbilt, the
wife of Alfred Vanderbilt II.
So she has these famous
and important friends
who see her as an
important woman,
and also in 1959 she was honored
alongside Lorraine Hansberry
for her commitment
to civic welfare.
So they're feting
Lorraine Hansberry,
and Mollie is right there
with Lorraine Hansberry.
I'm saying this just
to give you a sense
of the scope of her
popularity and the reach,
but she was also this
very polarizing figure.
So on the one hand,
she has the engine
of the black press
who's promoting
everything she's doing.
On the other hand-- except for
the Baltimore Afro-American.
They're not having anything--
they will critique her when
they feel like it's necessary,
but she's also the subject of
much scrutiny and criticism.
She's accused of
misappropriating funds,
and that was actually a very
interesting article to read,
where basically the
New York Amsterdam
News reports that the Urban
League is like, OK, hands off.
We're going to let
them figure it out
because a white
woman was claiming
that Mollie misappropriated
funds for events.
So they kind of took
a hands off approach
and let Molly handle it.
There was also lots of gossip
about her alleged affairs,
and in the mid 1960s, she sued
a very prominent and wealthy
white socialite for $1
million for defamation.
There was scrutiny about
her interracial approach
to race relations, and one of
the most fascinating things
I found on this was a
book by Chester Himes,
a social and political
satire called Pinktoes.
It was published in 1961--
where Moon is the inspiration
for the maligned protagonist
Mamie Mason.
And so Himes is
critical of Mamie Mason
and these interracial
parties that she
throws, which he considers
orgies for the racial uplift
cause.
And what's interesting
is that Himes
is first cousins to
Mollie's husband, Henry,
and so he was actually
living with Mollie and Henry
at the time that he's doing
all this research for the book.
And then he writes this scathing
piece on interracial race
relations and their
parties for the book.
Got to love family.
[LAUGHTER]
It's an interesting book.
You should check it out.
So in my last few
minutes, I want
to say a little bit specifically
about fundraising here.
So as I mentioned earlier, one
of Mollie's most popular events
was the Beaux-Arts Ball, which
she started hosting in 1942.
And these balls were
the major fundraisers
for the Urban League Guild.
As you can see here--
well, first let me point
out this is Mollie here.
Isn't that a hat?
That's a hat, isn't it?
So this is the Beaux-Arts
queen for that year.
Do you know who this is?
- [INAUDIBLE].
- Right.
So we got Josephine Baker here.
I mean, when Mollie can
make Josephine Baker look
like just a regular person
when she's like woo.
[LAUGHTER]
So I love this picture.
This is from another
ball, and remember,
they were costume balls,
so each year had a theme.
[? They're ?] [? looking ?] like
she's like, I hear you, bro,
but no.
Her body language here
is so interesting,
but this is another
one of the balls,
and then here's Mollie with
Gordon Parks and Gloria
Vanderbilt at another
one of the balls.
So these are the
major fundraisers.
They were public, and
it was the social event
of the year for
blacks in Harlem,
but also people traveling
from out of town
to attend this event.
And by 1955, the year after
Betty Granger's Amsterdam News
series on social leaders,
Mollie's Beaux-Arts ball
had raised nearly $420,000
in today's figures
for the Urban League.
And it was one of the most
popular events on the New York
social calendar,
which, as I mentioned,
brought together
celebrities, everyday folks,
philanthropists, and so forth.
And it was fueled by this
Miss Beaux-Arts pageant, which
is how I stumbled across
Mollie to begin with,
because one of
their pageant queens
was the face of this
white owned wig shop
that my black nationalist
folk, Kwame Brathwaite,
were protesting against.
So I was like, this
woman's a Beaux-Arts queen.
What's a Beaux-Arts queen?
So that's how I found Mollie--
through the pageant, which
was sponsored by the
Schaefer Brewing Company.
And they put forth
all this money
to fund the beauty pageant,
and each year people
would vote on a slate of
beauty queen contestants.
And they've noted in
the Amsterdam News
that they would have upwards
of a million people voting
for the Beaux-Arts
queen, so this just
gives you a sense of the scope.
But I don't want to go on
too much about these balls,
because at the end of the
day, a gala is a gala.
A lot of us have been
to those events before.
What I have found
fascinating is the emphasis
on these fashion shows--
fashion shows as fundraisers.
So they were common in the
early 20th century amongst
the original black 400 and
people like [? Bernie ?]
[? Austen ?] and Bessye Bearden,
and A'Lelia Walker would host
these events, these
fundraiser events,
that featured the fashions of
a lot of black women designers,
but with the Great Depression
and then also the rations
on textiles during World War II
they kind of fell out of vogue.
But when I looked through
some of the clippings
in terms of where
Mollie was going
or what the Urban
League Guild was up to,
they decided to host their
Urban League Guild executive
meeting in Chicago during--
to coincide with
the Urban Aid's,
which was like the local Chicago
version of the Urban League
Guild--
their annual fashion show
to see if that model which
had been successful in
Chicago could be a fundraising
model they could
implement in other guilds
across the country.
So it looks to me that
Mollie does decide
that fashion shows would be
good fundraisers for the Guild,
and by 1959 not
only are the fashion
shows regular fundraisers,
Mollie partners
with Eunice Johnson, who is the
founder of the Ebony Fashion
Fair and wife of John Johnson,
who, of course, owns Johnson
Publication-- so Ebony,
Jet, Negro Digest-- to bring
the Ebony Fashion Fair
to the Waldorf Astoria
in New York in 1959.
And I don't know about
you all, but I grew up--
we had Ebony Fashion Fair in
my hometown when I grew up.
It was a big thing, but I never
realized what the fashion fair
was other than a fashion fair.
A local organization
would host the fair,
and they would use
the moneys raised
to support whatever cause
was the cause of that year
for the organization.
So by the time
Mollie had brought
the fashion fair
to New York City,
the fair had traveled to
51 cities and 31 states.
Enter Mary McLeod Bethune,
who I mentioned earlier,
who, at this point
in the late 1940s,
is still the President of the
National Association of Negro
Women.
And she sponsors the creation
of the National Association
of Fashion and
Accessories Designers.
We'll just call it NAFAD.
So I say late '40s because
this is when NAFAD is founded.
So by the time we
get to the late 1950s
when these fashion
shows are very common,
we have an organization
for black women fashion
and accessories designers.
Now think about this.
In this era of Jim Crow,
the fashion industry
was segregated.
So these black women
who were trying
to move from being deemed as
seamstresses to being designers
are now trying to get work in
the haute couture industry,
but they can't find jobs.
So NAFAD becomes a
vehicle through which
they can work on
professionalization, where
they can develop their craft.
They can establish and extend
their professional networks.
And it becomes a place where
they can brand themselves
as designers.
And so NAFAD helped launch
the careers of people
like Lois Alexander,
who now a lot of people
know because she designed
Jackie Kennedy's wedding gown.
And Zelda Wynn Valdes--
I'm writing a piece for
Valdes for the New York
Times that will hopefully
be published in a few days.
But they are using these
fashion show fundraisers
as a way to launch their
career, so very much we
see this emphasis on equality
in all types of employment
industries and the
rise in fashion
shows as fundraisers
as interlocked.
And I think it's
really important
to think about Mary McLeod
Bethune in this moment,
because I think that the
way we've constructed her
as a woman who's interested
in the equality of women,
and women's rights, and also
black education-- we wouldn't
associate her with something
like fashion, which
people think is frivolous.
But what she says--
this is another industry
where black women need work.
This is another
industry where we're
trying to cast off this
idea of black women
as servants or in the
servile industries
that the language
like seamstress
had historically
evoked for black women.
So I'm still trying
to weave together
this fashion show
piece, but I think
it's going to be really
critical to the book--
this fashion as
fundraiser piece.
I have about five minutes left.
I'm going to conclude here.
So my research assistant
found this article
in the New York Amsterdam
News, and when I saw it,
I cracked up,
because does anybody
know what chitterlings are,
or chitlins, as we call them?
So sell chitlin dinners
to decorate lobby.
And Mollie's name is
mentioned in this story,
and I'm like, whoa, OK.
Everything that they've
tried to do to create
this image of glamor--
chitlins ain't that.
[LAUGHTER]
It's these pig intestine
scraps that black folks have
turned into fine cuisine
in our community.
Listen, for people
who still eat pork,
when the chitlins hit the
table during Thanksgiving,
this is a big deal.
My mom thinks she
can make chitlins.
[LAUGHTER]
I don't eat pork no
more, so I don't even
have to contend with that.
I don't have to tell
her if she can or can't.
I don't think she
probably can, though.
So to me, when I think
about this idea of selling
chitlin dinners, this type of
fundraising that we associate
with the black church--
when you have a building
fund, it takes you 10 years,
and you still haven't built
one new part of the building,
but it's funded off of these
chicken dinners, and chitlin
dinners, and so on and so forth.
So the fact that they
were using this language
to talk about society
women I found interesting.
Now, if you look at the
year here, this is 1973.
And so for me, I'm intrigued
not just by the chitlins piece,
but by the year,
because by '73 when
we're in this kind of height of
the black power and soul era,
you have these
socialite women who
are reclaiming these quaint
southern culinary traditions.
And I thought this was really
interesting, especially
after reading all this stuff
and learning information
about all the top black
women caterers who would
cater these private events.
I've learned so much
about vintage champagne,
because that was
the thing to have.
Everybody had vintage champagne.
Gordon Parks threw a
party at his summer house
where he had 12 cases
of vintage champagne,
and 100 pounds of
barbecued chicken,
and so on and so forth.
So to see this piece
that's dealing with--
that's talking about
selling chitlin dinners
to decorate a lobby.
It's one of these coteries
who probably came up
the ranks through the fashion
shows that Molly hosted who's
trying to redecorate the lobby
of her high rise apartments
in Harlem.
And so they're selling chitlin
dinners as a way to do this.
And so I'm intrigued by
this because I want to know,
is there another shift that
happens in black society
life in the 1970s?
Where does this story go?
Because I feel like I'm
starting to get a handle
on Mollie's
generation, how they're
defining glamor, and high
society, and black life,
and who gets to be
in, and who isn't in.
But what happens when we get to
that black power movement era
where there starts
to be more pushback
against interracial
activism, when
the critiques against
capitalism and imperialism
reach this fever pitch?
I want to know what happens to
Mollie and people of her ilk.
We know Mollie still
continues to be
the president of the
Urban League Guild
because she reigns for 50 years.
That is a long time.
I'm sorry.
Every time I hear that figure--
but I'm interested to see
what changes, because--
I guess I do have two minutes.
I can say this.
The book end for me in terms of
how I'm thinking about it now--
who knows what will
happen when it actually
becomes a book project?
But Desiree Rogers, for
me, is an important figure
that links the Mollie Moon
era with this more present
and contemporary moment.
She's the first social secretary
of the Obama administration,
and she's from New Orleans.
She's a self-proclaimed
descendant of New Orleans
voodoo queen and
socialite Marie Laveau,
but doesn't
everybody say they're
the descendant of Marie Laveau?
Everybody says that, right?
But she's claiming there's a
certain multigenerational tie
to hosting and being able to
work closely with the most
powerful people in a society.
And so she's saying I come
from a particular tradition
of fundraising.
And so before she
becomes social secretary,
she gets the gig because
of her uncanny ability
to raise money for
Obama's 2008 campaign.
So this Harvard
MBA hosted events
for Chicago's white and black
business elite in her home
and used her training
and marketing
to, quote unquote, "brand"
Obama for the social media
generation, but her visibility
also made her a target.
I don't know if you all
remember that two reality TV
stars crashed the White
House state dinner,
and Desiree Rogers is forced to
fall on her sword and resign.
But part of the
reason why I think
that she's forced to resign
is because she's so visible.
Here's an article of her on the
cover of Wall Street Journal.
Before we were thinking
about Michelle Obama
as this fashionista
and beauty image,
it was Desiree Rogers who was
branding herself like this.
In true black
society woman form,
she was using the media as a
way to not only brand Obama,
but brand herself,
and social secretaries
had never before done that.
How many social
secretaries can you name?
But you can name her.
And she goes on
after she's dismissed
to become the CEO of
Johnson Publications.
So I think that is very
interesting, because we've
seen how Mollie
partnered with Johnson
Publications and the
Ebony Fashion Fair
in the mid 20th century.
So this just shows how small
this black elite community is.
So I'm trying to
figure out, what
is this meaty middle
tissue in the '70s, '80s,
and early '90s that gives us
someone like a Desiree Rogers
and someone who still sees
herself as very much wedded
to these traditions
of socialite activism
and fundraising of
her foremothers?
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]